let's say you're going to Brazil for the
World Cup here's what you'll see as soon
as you step off the plane expect some
traffic on your way to the game and when
you finally get there a hardhat might
come in handy
take South Paulo's 365 million-dollar
Stadium it's been a scramble to get it
finished in time for the opening kickoff
on June 12th with just weeks to go
entire sections still had no seats and
much of the roof wasn't installed
outside this was supposed to be a huge
parking lot designed to hold dozens of
buses the inaugural match in May was
barely able to accommodate a half-size
crowd now imagine what will happen when
they try to pack in twice as many people
it could be a security nightmare some of
the challenges of stadiums the parking
around the stadiums
the uncertainty of where is that we're
going to be able to go or not going it's
an uphill battle for all of us that have
the responsibility of protecting these
folks the World Cup is the biggest
sporting event on the planet so why is
it Brazil ready
we are incompetent everybody knows that
we have no plan in the country why
should we have for the vertical but the
country is now is in a very difficult
situation Brazil spent 3.6 billion
dollars to build a remodeled stadiums in
12 cities only three were delivered on
time federal and state governments
earmarked 14 billion to improve the
country's poor infrastructure only to
encounter more delays the new terminal
at Sao Paulo's overcrowded airport won't
be completed until after the World Cup
is over and this airport renovation in
Belo Horizonte is months behind schedule
even Rio Brazil's tourism Mecca did
little to fix the problems that lead to
epic traffic jams way up north in the
Amazon there's a city closer to being
ready for the flood of soccer fans
Manaus a jungle boom town here we are
three weeks from the beginning of the
World Cup how much work do you have left
without all remedy to muskoka quit fuzzy
no that's on the Kansas Russia Aakansha
Nadu
yeah no problem mother nature the
Rangers - exactly Manaus will host one
of the biggest matches of the World Cup
England vs. Italy on June 14th
everybody in Brazil knows it's very
important for us not only from another
for everywhere in Brazil you are a poor
city we need to prove that we are able
to receive 100,000 people that we are
prepared to manage great events because
we do trust in our future for certain
tourist fee that's what's really at
stake not whether they'll come for the
World Cup but whether they'll come back